is the prostitution to support the drug
habit no no
i i get a thrill off the sex too
just the fact of a new man every time
there's something exciting about it
it gets me off every time
i've been with more than 4 000 men
it's a lot of people
all right ginger yeah ginger where'd you
grow up where you're from
originally compton california compton
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid
back and forth they had shared custody
most of the time the weekdays with my
dad and then the weekends with my mom
how do you describe your childhood
[ __ ] up real [ __ ] up
i didn't have my mom like i wanted or
two and i'm doing the same thing to my
kids
i'm doing the same exact thing
i'm messed up myself i mean i never
spanked my kids but
i'm not being it's like a repeating
cycle
i hate myself for that
it's not like how i planned it when i
was
19 years old i wanted to have to be the
perfect mom but
things don't go well when you plant them
you can never do for me at least
what kind of stuff did you go through as
a child
my dad used to whoop me and hit me a lot
anywhere like across my head
my sister would come home from school
and uh she peed on herself so i would
try to hurry up and
put her on something else and he would
catch me with me for that
i was abused
physically yeah verbally too
verbally too he would leave us i wake up
in the middle of the night
four and six years old he wouldn't be
there and i'd be screaming for help out
the doorway and
it's [ __ ] up it was [ __ ] up
you went on your own at what age huh you
went on your own at what age
around 15 i moved in with my mom because
i told the social worker that my dad was
hitting me and beat me too much and i
got sick and tired of it
his wife at the time
tammy i couldn't stand her either
i was suicidal i was
being visited by a psychiatrist in the
ninth grade
then my grandmother hired to speak to me
and pull me out of class every once in a
while
it's horrible and then you were working
as a prostitute since when
i've always wanted to be a hooker since
i was seven
but i've worked as a prostitute since i
was
give or take 18 years old
i'm 40 going on 41 though and how did
that start for you
started off as man pulling over and
offering me money
and it went from there i had a couple of
pimps and
it's just too much my life has been very
busy
i haven't stopped it's called being
turned out
i can't stop it's like a magnet
it's hard it's not hard to stop it for
some people for me it is
what is it that draws you to it i've
heard a lot of people say that they're
addicted to the lifestyle i'm addicted
to the money
addicted to
the fact that i'm going to do the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over
i'm not addicted to the fact that maybe
i'll get in the car that might pull a
gun on me again
i've had four guns drawn on me the last
one being the tech nine
and um i asked him to
it was stupid but i asked him when he's
ready to come back and
apologize and he did and i dated him
still
that's how risky my life is and how much
of a gamble
is that i'll do anything for the money
it's [ __ ] up are you using crack
i use all types of drugs
i don't let that get the best of me
because
it shouldn't um
but that's not the reason why i'm doing
it
that's not the reason why i was doing
this
way long before i mean i started smoking
weed i
lied and smoking cigarettes in seven but
the harder drugs started when
16 years old in my senior year
at ganesha high in pomona but you're
saying
the the prostitution started
starting at 18. yeah but uh but which
one caused
it is the prostitution to support the
drug habit
no no i i get a thrill off the sex too
just the fact of a new man every time
there's something exciting
about it it gets me off every time
i've been with more than four thousand
men
it's a lot of people it's a lot
what do you think having four 000 sexual
partners
does to a person wears them out
where is you out i'm uh no but uh but
mentally
there there's nothing someone could tell
me about the male anatomy i know it from
front to back there's nothing not even
the man himself he ends up giving up
like okay you got me i'm like
look i know already what's about to
happen you either can hold it in or not
i said well i know what you're doing you
know
and they usually give up
um i've had some good experiences
and some bad ones but i'm not gonna let
the bad ones override my good ones
do you respect the men that pick you up
i totally respect them to the fullest
they're lonely and they need love to
officers pick me up too you know it's
all walks of lives you got
every organization you can imagine
that i've been picked up by i wouldn't
rule out nothing i'm saying every agency
every organization they know who they
are
they know who they are and we're good
friends to this day and you know how to
keep a secret
i'm not going to say the name of the
organization yeah um but
they know who they are and i'm just
highly affiliated with a lot of things
you're probably watching these videos
probably so you uh
but we're still friends what's the
craziest thing you've seen in all your
years of doing this
whoa i've seen some crazy
i've been in things and crazy i've
seen one of my dates go as far as and
throwing body parts in the trash
and talking to me at the same time it
doesn't bother me because to maintain
the sanity and not get into that
position
you must act accordingly like a lady i
mean i've had some crazy
serial rapists say you know what you're
crazier than me get out
and i didn't find out that they were
like that until i seen a description on
the news i'm like oh my god i just dated
that guy
you know and and i became one of the
survivors out of a lot of situations
because
i knew how to conduct myself you know
i'm crazy for being with a crazy person
what do you think there was about your
upbringing that put you on this this
path
well i mean being molested by some
family members and
going in the bathroom and seeing a bunch
of dirty magazines in there
growing up watching elvira most
seven-year-old girls don't dream about
becoming a product oh my dad used to
catch me in the bathroom taking off my
pants from school
and i'd have fish nets on he's like
where are you getting these
sexy stockings from and i'm like
i didn't want to tell them but i was
buying them you know
i had a um a desire for sex since i was
four
i remember being at a little tea party
me and my cousin my sister and i said
when i grow up i'm gonna suck my
husband's [ __ ] i don't know where it
came from
but it did and that's what totally meant
you know
there are all types of girls in this
world that have sexual desires at a very
young age
i didn't mind having orgasms at the age
of 13.
most women are still trying i'm like wow
what's the what's the whole
thing behind it i mean it's easier your
genetics just let you let you there
or or is it the molestation no it's just
the whole
turn all about it like sex period
i just i'm into it you're into it i'm
into like a [ __ ]
i really love sex a lot i can't hide
that about myself
i find it interesting since i was a kid
i just i like the whole how people go
through their
whole acts and then to have sex you know
like
i was running across the street like two
weeks ago and i said
suck my [ __ ] but i was having a moment
and this
[ __ ] he picks me up he said i'll
suck your dick and
i get in the car and he starts dolling
himself up putting a wiggle on and stuff
and i said well what am i what am i
gonna get if you he said sixty thousand
[ __ ] dollars then i gave up
for a date
yeah last week i did one for 1300 just
to stand around and smoke crack
so the guy who offered you six how much
sixty thousand
i think it was to go to um calabasas
he was um he had money and i said you
know what i was just
venting you know i really don't have a
dick he goes well i'll eat your [ __ ]
and i go
oh my god i go i i didn't want to go
that far
you know even though i could have it's a
long drive there's been a lot of dates
that i've thrown off millions and
millions of dollars
i just wasn't feeling it i didn't like
the distance maybe
right but with all this all these
partners all the business that you've
done
i'm clean as a whistle have you saved
money
i've put it towards other things i
probably made other millionaires
um invested in some things
um there isn't one person that don't
need a hooker
no one's exempt and it's to the point
where it's like get this straight i have
my own life
i'm not a [ __ ] robot
i too have feelings you know what i'm
saying i cry
like like anyone would and and i and i
have feelings
stop you know thinking i'm some [ __ ]
mule
you know and i'm not but i love what i
do
and my grandmother told me before she
passed away just whatever it is you do
be the best of what the [ __ ] it is don't
don't ever be ashamed of it i'm not
i'm not it's so many people don't even
know everyone's a prostitute
everyone prostitutes himself a day just
to make a dollar you got to do it
i just do things differently and i'm not
a home wrecker
no i don't wear victoria's secrets
perfumes and stuff
i don't wear makeup i'm just looking for
my money and i go
i'm not trying to break a happy home or
family
it's not my have you been in love before
huh have you been in love before
i don't know what that is because if i
was in love those people will still be
my life
so unless love taps me on the shoulder
and say hey i'm love
no i don't know what love is and i've
never been married how many kids you
have
three did you raise them somewhat
they know who i am they know how crazy i
am they know their mom's a prostitute
and they still love me
um 21 17 and the 12 year old's going on
48.
she's real mature for her age um
they know i'm a hooker and if anyone
wants to down talk me right now in front
of them they will
rip your [ __ ] head off because i am
who i am
and i always taught them don't let
nobody tell you different that i don't
love you i do
i'm just living my life
i wasn't ready to have kids early or
period i never wanted kids
but things happen and i'm not going to
get no abortion just because someone
thinks it's a bad idea
i love my kids my children excuse me i
love my children
nothing's gonna change that
it tears me up every day to think wow
you not being present in your life
you're a bad mother
well i hope god understands
joy does
are you religious i believe in god i
don't believe in jesus
that's it what do you worry about
my kids not accepting me
it's all right i don't have time to
worry about no one else
but my children i check them every once
in a while
like i said they know who i am who
raised them
meme their dad is raising them currently
the two girls
and my mom has my son he's 21.
just go out of the army um
they're all good i call them everyone
small we're all good
do you have friends hell no i don't know
what a friend is
i'm a virgo i don't know what a friend
is
the only last three these so-called
people in the last three months in my
life if that and then they vanished
so the only friend i have is god
and me what's been the worst time of
your life
never nothing what's been the best time
now
i'm not in jail
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
just don't change for nobody and be me
not sit there and change or gallivant
amongst people that
won't accept me if you don't accept me
you ain't got to it sounds like you feel
no shame
don't for anything for nothing i won't
stress or grow white hair
or bust a wrinkle for no one's ass
not even for myself i don't feel sorry
for myself at all
so you described yourself as happy
over happy just just i'm i'm even though
i
have tears for some things i can't beat
myself up all day
i gotta be happy i am in jail so
and you're still working today i was
working a few hours ago
i stopped the date actually to be over
here so he's still sitting over there
what uh
so so what's what streets do you work or
or have you worked
sephora beach van buren
i made my own and big rear lake pine
avenue
just in case somebody wants to find you
okay someone wants to find me
um holt in pomona i'm a real star out
there
i think some of these videos function as
advertising for some of you ladies too
cool i got major love for hope boulevard
they got love for me too they love me i
left that city dry when i left
try all i heard was his crickets and
tumbleweeds now
so i guess that makes me a big part of
uh
i don't know being a local celebrity in
samaras
tell me about your take on pimps well
what on pimps
what do you mean like uh do you think
having a pimp is a good idea or
what's the upside and downside of having
i mean i could be one
there is no for women who think that's a
bad idea to have a pimp you're
totally wrong what a pimp is a man
that'll take care of you
give you money do all types of things
bodyguard whatever
a woman out there alone which is a
renegade
will end up getting killed because she
has no structure
and then that gives a man supposedly a
right on the streets to disrespect her
which i don't like seeing she'll get
killed by
guerrilla pimps they work in groups
numbers and they'll dog walk a [ __ ]
just drag her ass and kill her
i seen it happen i've seen it happen
i've seen women killed
because of my happiness being put at
stake and i couldn't get
what i wanted and i've seen a whole
fleet of women get killed
all because they were taking the meal
out of my plate so
it's really not a game
out there is not a game ain't no
[ __ ] game
so if you're waking up in the morning
you think it's going to be a good idea
to be
a freelancing cooker one day you better
look into it
because you could seriously get hurt
found in the dumpster an alley
somewhere you got to know somebody
ain't gotta necessarily be pimp it could
be folks
family that are affiliated in the
streets that are watching over you and
you gotta make that known cause if you
don't
somebody can hurt you it's a person that
won't do their homework
so this kind of work is not for every
girl it ain't cut out for every woman
you gotta have it in your bones you
gotta it's something you gotta
know you can do i mean you just don't
wake up in like a pretty woman no
it doesn't happen like that no
do you have dreams of being saved that
is that idea i mean do you have
do you hope some guy might come along
and and save you from this
hell no that'll only be god my savior
there ain't no man i can do that other
than him so
nope you have to be crazy
to do this kind of work oh my god it's a
gamble it's a risk every second of your
life i've had guns put on me that's what
i'm hearing after doing so many
nice i've i've dated mass
murderer serial killers rapist
and i'm a survivor are you turned on by
that
no like i told you i don't find it until
after like
good thing i acted presumably like a
lady i mean
you got to be a fool not to know how to
pass the test and for all you ladies
don't know what the test is
if a man drops money on the ground or if
you see it
do the right thing and hand it to them
because you're going to get it anyway
once you start thinking you're slicker
than them or that they're not playing
drunk
they might cut your head off or kill you
that's how usually it happens so
do the right thing give them their money
and when they ask you well why did you
do that you said
silly you're going to give it to me
anyways so and they almost like here you
go
don't ever fall for the okie doke and
think that they're drunk they're never
drunk they know they've been through
this a million times
you know they're there's never a dumb
john out there
they're always brilliant they just want
to see where your hair is
always some games being played not
necessarily games more like text
tests all the time everything every move
you make
watch yourself carefully don't go in
this
industry looking for trouble like that
to begin with i don't the women that are
carrying the lives the guns
they're looking for that i don't care
[ __ ]
i ain't looking for nothing but my money
why do i need that to protect myself
i shouldn't even be in that situation so
don't you need protection no just do
be simple keep it simple that's it
keep it simple your intuition is
probably a valuable tool right very
fine feeling you ain't feeling and after
4 000 guys you probably get a
heightened sense of who's safe oh [ __ ]
i know where to go what do you look for
i don't go look for they would no no
what what what behaviors do you sense
are
trouble in a in a guy in a trick
i love tricks there's a difference
between the john and the trick
what's the difference between a job is a
man
who will jack off rolling next to you
with his windows rolled up and his car
is like and he's not gonna let you in
ever and he continues to drive around in
circles
never gonna pull over for you unless you
throw a brick through there without
something but
but your definition of it john is a guy
who'll take you up and have sex for me
no not necessarily i've never i've not
had sex with all these men
there's been times where i've had to
clean a house or no
be a nurse walk a dog
serve some people papers not necessarily
everything a prosecutor's picked up is
for that
sometimes they want to just sit and talk
and pick my brain
professors not everything is a sex
school if that's
what turns them on i'm there for it
other than that
i haven't had sex with all of them i
sell dreams
i mean they're easier to sell
if a man knows he can get you easy he
ain't gonna be back
most of the men i've been with for
hundreds and thousands
we don't have sex we just wanted company
and if you do have sex he'll come but if
not oh well
nothing it's an interesting lifestyle
you lead it's been one crazy hell of a
life
but everybody got to do something in
life
and i was just called to do this and now
and i'm not gonna sit here and be like
oh feel sorry for me don't
and if you do then do i mean i wouldn't
advise it for nobody
it's not for everybody all right ginger
thank you so much for talking with me
thank you
i wish you the best of luck out there
you too thank you